- Alright, y'all, welcome back.
- We've got Taika Waititi here with us.
(audience claps and cheers)
You may know our next
guest as Elaine's boss,
Jay Peterman on Seinfeld,
or as the voice of King Neptune
on SpongeBob Squarepants, in my household.
But to every dog lover out there,
he's known as the host
of The National Dog Show,
which airs tomorrow,
Thanksgiving Day on NBC.
Please welcome John O'Hurley
along with a couple of
his best friends, y'all.
(crowd cheering)
(instrumental music)
(instrument music)
(crowd clapping and cheering)
Oh my Gosh.
_ [Taika] I'll take him.
- I want to cuddle with you.
- [John] You have a job.
- [Taika Waititi] Okay, great.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh wait,
uou have a job. (laughs)
- Come here sweetheart.
- Your character changed.
- [John O'Hurley] This is Ani and Thyme,
right here.
- [Kelly] Aww. Very cute. I
love that you came with dogs.
Are you a dog person?
Did you have dogs growing up?
- [Taika Waititi] Yes, I did. Yep. Yep.
Many dogs.
And a canary.
- [John O'Hurley] You remember
one of them, in particular?
- [Kelly] Birds are hard in a household.
- Yeah. Rex very original name for my dog.
(John laughs)
- [Kelly] He's a Rex. It
was like such amazing name.
- That's amazing.
I love when they name him
like old dudes like Bill.
It's like,
Well what's your favorite
breed like at the shows?
You've done so many. Over 20 years now.
- [John] 22 years we've
been doing the show.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, usually I kill a show before then.
(Kelly laughs)
My favorite is the Irish setter.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Neck is very erect.
- [Kelly] Beautiful.
- Beautiful auburn hair
on the blue rug as it comes out.
It always looks like the redhead
that just walked into the cocktail party.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Aww.
- There it is right there you see.
Oh, it's just beautiful.
- I love it.
So it's like I said, it's-
- Not a dog I would own
- [Kelly] It's been over, Why?
- Well, they're very active.
I mean, you, you need a
lot of property to have a,
I mean they're meant to
be bird dogs or a setter.
- Yeah, I get that.
- As opposed to you.
- That's very respectful.
So wait, over over 20
years, what's like one
of the most memorable
moments at the dog show?
- [Audience] Aww.
- Well.
I would say the,
Oh gosh, a few years back
during the best in show round,
which is where the top seven dogs
are there,
- [Kelly] Mm-hmm.
- one of them is gonna
be chosen best in show
and it's the Great Dane that
happens to be sauntering
by the NBC booth.
Stops in its tracks,
looks me straight in the eye,
squats down and leaves
what I would refer to
as an editorial comment
right on the floor,
(audience laughs)
right there.
And it stopped the entire show
while the hazmat team
comes out (Taisa laughs)
with the elephant shovels
and has to clean things up.
- The only way
- But that's the only time
that's happened
- this story gets
even better is if that
dog won Best in show.
(John laughs)
- It it is kind of self
disqualifying, unfortunately.
- Oh, man. Would've been
funny though. (laughs)
Do you remember when they
first asked you to host?
'cause it was such a random thing, right?
- Well, yes.
They asked me to host
and they didn't know what,
everybody was flying blind
the first year, including me.
'cause I had never been to a dog show.
I didn't know anything about them.
They brought the old English sheep dog
up to the judge.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh yeah.
If you don't know what an
old English sheep dog is.
- Very hairy.
- Yeah. It's 80 pounds of hair
and two pounds of actual dog.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah. (audience laughs)
Which is awesome.
- They brought it up to the judge,
who was this elegantly gowned woman.
So she walks around to
the front of the dog
and she starts picking through all
of the hair on the dog's head.
And I said, David, what is she doing now?
He says, John, she's
trying to find the eyes
(audience laughs)
to gauge the attentiveness of the dog.
I said, really?
Well, she picks through all of
that hair and she finds only one eye.
She's got the wrong end of the dog.
(Kelly laughs)
So you see how far my learning curve was?
- You said it on air, right?
- Yeah. Oh yes.
- Oh, I love you so much.
And it turned into the, you know,
they have the broadcaster's comments
in the sports section
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah,
that would be the one.
- and US today.
That was it.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Wrong end of the dog, John O'hurley.
(Kelly laughs) (audience laughs)
- Okay. So you have such a great voice,
so have you ever done,
do you wanna, I think the dog
wants to go for a walk.
(audience laughs)
(John and Kelly laugh) (audience claps)
(John laughs) (audience laughs and claps)
Oh my God. I love you so much.
She said to the dog,
turn around, come back.
- [Taika Waititi] Take him back.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Out for your morning
Constitutional were you?
(John laughs)
- Physical comedy is the best.
Oh my God, I love you so much.
- Now, don't you try that.
(audience laughs)
- Be sure to watch The
National Dog Show tomorrow
along with my sister who never misses it.
Thanksgiving day on NBC.